[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marleau
d'accord
jacques c'est de la triche music machine
à fumée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la 6e polonais
c'est en tous les cas on est en tous les
cas alors je ne sais pas j'ai lancé ma
carrière
[Applaudissements]
alors attendez vous passerez il faut
passer l'épilation un sur le dos un nom
mais allez-y vous puissiez vous aussi ce
qu'on ce qu'on a fait de façon comme
d'habitude assez j'avais dit relatifs à
nadal alors certains diront artisanale
d'autres diront dégueulasse bonjour
dégueulasse les artistes
justement c'est parce que je respecte
les artistes que je voudrais c'est pas
du tout on est d'accord non jusqu'au
cette émission-là pourrait arriver sur
tf1 puisque arthur arracher les droits
d'un prime qui s'appelle c'est le fan de
jean claude bourdeau des célébrités huit
hommes et femmes qui vont avoir une
semaine pourquoi barre et 18
c'est vrai même l'addition saint-puy
environ une semaine pourquoi parascript
et souhaite filmer de la répétition à la
représentation devant une centaine de
personnes et ça vise apparemment à
sensibiliser contre le cancer des seins
par les femmes et des testicules pour
les aminches tout ça me paraît assez
logique de sa femme politique hull
hommes
cela va bien on regarde et on a toutes
les images et on vous explique tout moi
je voulais les voir mais franchement
j'aime bien les balles franchement
j'aime bien après avoir fait glisser les
stars sur son décor pencher arthur est
de retour avec un nouveau concept
étonnant cette fois ci il a décidé de
les mettre à poil l'animateur producteur
vient d'acquérir les droits du programme
gouvernance à l'origine intitulé there
will full monty qui propose à ses stars
de préparer durant une semaine un strip
tease dans les règles de l'art qu'ils
devront ensuite réalisé à la télévision
un format qui existe déjà en angleterre
et là bas c'est un vrai carton
tout comme dans danse avec les stars les
célébrités qui se prêteront à cet
exercice seront filmés tout au long de
la semaine durant les entraînements le
but de cette émission est également
caritatives
elle s'est donnée pour mission de
sensibiliser les téléspectateurs à
l'importance du dépistage du cancer du
sein chez les femmes et du cancer du
testicule ou de la prostate chez les
hommes pour le moment tf1 n'a pas
précisé si elle était intéressée ou non
par ce projet que j'attendais moi
personnellement oui j'ai envie de voir
des personnalités nu surtout si c'est
pour une bonne cause et je trouve que
j'en avais ras-le-bol de voir les
personnalités sur son décor penche un
peu plus c'est toujours les mêmes trucs
c'est bien c'est novateur
bravo arthur refuser la wii on est
content